another key developer responsible for
diablo 3 has left Blizzard
Entertainment's a few days ago Blizzard
posted a job listing for a game director
to take the lead on the Diablo series
this was a little confusing to most of
us as diablo 3 already had a game
director josh mascara well as it happens
Blizzard has now confirmed that mascara
has in fact left the company completely
Blizzard told polygon with Diablo 3 in a
good place at this point Josh felt that
now was a good time to pursue other
opportunities with minimal impact to the
team will be filling the director role
either from within blizzard or
externally mascara replaced jay wilson
as diablo 3's game director in 2013 who
subsequently left blizzard and the games
industry completely in june 2016 diablo
3 lead designer leonard boyarsky also
left the company back in april on the
upside the new job listing appears to
suggest a new diablo project is in the
works although what that will be exactly
remains to be seen according to the job
description the successful candidate
will quote lead the Diablo series into
the future let me know what you want to
see next from the Diablo series and for
all the latest musi bits and pieces stay
tuned to games but
you